we've got the function f of x is equal
to x to the third power minus 12 x plus
two and what i want to do in this video
is think about at what points does my
function f take on minimum or maximum
values and to figure that out i have to
first figure out what are the critical
points for my function f and then which
of those critical points do we achieve a
minimum or maximum value and to
determine the critical points we have to
find the derivative of our function
because our critical points are just the
point at which our derivative is either
equal to zero or undefined so the
derivative of this thing right over here
we're just going to use the power rule
several times and then i guess you could
call it the constant rule but the
derivative of x to the third is 3
x squared derivative of negative 12x is
negative 12 and the derivative of a
constant it doesn't change with respect
to x so it's just going to be equal to
0.
so we're going to get a critical point
when this thing right over here for some
value of x is either undefined or zero
well this thing is defined for all
values of x so the only places we're
going to find critical points is when
this thing is equal to zero so let's set
it equal to zero when does 3x squared
minus 12 equals zero so let's add 12 to
both sides you get 3x squared is equal
to 12 divide both sides by 3 you get x
squared is equal to 4. well this is
going to happen when x is equal to 2
and x is equal to negative
and x is equal to negative 2. just to be
clear
f of 2
is equal or let me be clear f prime of 2
you get 3 times 4 minus 12 which is
equal to 0 and f prime of negative two
is also same exact reason is also equal
to zero so we can say and i'll switch
colors here that that
f has
critical points
critical points
at
x equals 2
and x equals negative 2. well that's
fair enough but we still don't know
whether their minimum point where the
function takes on minimum values at
those points maximum values of those
points or neither to figure that out we
have to figure out whether the
derivative changes signs around these
points so let's actually try to graph
the derivative to think about this so
let's graph so i'll draw an axis right
over here
i'll do it down here because maybe we
can use that information later on to
graph f of x so let's say
so let's say this is my
x-axis
this is my
this is my
y-axis and so we have critical points at
x is equal to positive 2 so it's 1
2 and x is equal to negative 2.
1
2 x is equal to negative 2. so what is
this what does this derivative look like
if we wanted to graph it well we have a
when x is equal to 0 for the derivative
we're at negative 12 so this is the
point y is equal to negative 12. so this
is we're graphing y is equal to f prime
of x
so it looks something like this it will
look something
something
like this these are obviously the zeros
of our derivative so it has to move up
to cross the x-axis there and over here
and over
here
so what is the derivative doing at each
of these critical points well over here
our derivative is crossing from being
positive we have a positive negative
derivative to being a negative
derivative so we're crossing from being
a positive derivative to being a
negative derivative that was our
criteria for critical point to be a
maximum point
for being a
maximum point over here we're crossing
from a
we're crossing from a negative
derivative to a positive derivative
which is our criteria for a critical
point to
for the function to have a minimum value
at a critical point so a minimum and i
just want to make sure we have the
derivative we have the correct intuition
if our function if some function is
increasing going into some point so if
it's increasing going into some point
and at that point we see actually we
have a derivative of zero the derivative
could also be undefined we have a
derivative of zero and then the function
begins decreasing
that's why this would be a maximum point
similarly if we have a situation where
the function is decreasing going into a
point the derivative is negative
remember this is the graph of the
derivative let me make this clear this
is the graph of y is equal to not f of x
but f prime of x so if we have a
situation we're going into the point the
function is the function has a negative
slope we see we have a negative slope
here so the function might look
something like this
and then right at this point the
function is either undefined or has zero
slope so in this case it has zero slope
and then after that point
let me do it right under it
so going into it we have a negative
slope
and then right over here we have a zero
slope which i could draw it even better
than that
so if we were to imagine going into it
we have a negative slope right at that
point we have a zero slope and then we
have a positive slope
so the function begins increasing that's
why we say it has we have a minimum
point right over there so what i did
right over here is to try to
conceptualize what the function itself
could look like given the derivative in
this case switching from a positive
derivative to a negative derivative
across that critical point or going from
a negative derivative to a positive
derivative that's why this is a criteria
for a maximum point this is a criteria
for a minimum point well with that out
of the way can we use this intuition
that we just talked about to at least
try to sketch the graph of f x so let's
try to do it
let's try to do it
so let's try to do it and it's just
going to be a sketch it's not going to
be very exact but at least it'll give us
a sense of the shape of what f of x
looks like
so my best attempt
so it might not be drawn completely to
scale
so it's my x-axis
this is my y-axis we know we have a
critical point
at x is equal to positive two and we
have a critical point
at x is equal to
and we have a critical point at x is
equal to negative two we know just from
inspection that the y-intercept right
here of the graph of y is equal to f of
x when x is zero f of x is two so we're
going to hit right over
let's say we're going to hit right over
i want to give it i don't want to draw
this completely to the same scale as the
x axis so let's say that this is 2
let's say that this is 2 right over here
so this is where we're going to cross
this is going to be our y-intercept and
so we said already that we have a
maximum point at x is equal to negative
2. so what is f of negative 2
f of
f of negative 2 is equal to
8 or negative 8. let me be careful it's
negative 8 and then we're going to have
12 times negative 2 which is negative 24
but then we're going to add it so we're
subtracting negative 24. so this is plus
plus 24 and then we finally have plus 2.
so negative 8 plus 24
plus 2 so that's going to be negative
see negative 8 plus 24 is 16 plus 2 is
18. so f of negative 2 is equal to 18.
and i'm not drawing it completely scale
but let's say that this is 18 right over
here
so this is the function
this is the point negative 2 comma 18
and we know that it's a maximum point
the derivative going into that point is
negative
the derivative going into that point is
negative oh sorry the derivative going
into that point is positive so we are
increasing
we are increasing the slope is positive
and then after we cross that point the
slope becomes negative the slope becomes
negative the derivative crossed the
x-axis the slope becomes negative
look might actually i want to use that
same color it looks like this
it looks
like this
and then of course the graph is going to
cross the
it's going to have a y-intercept
something like that
and then
and then as we approach 2 we are
approaching another critical point now
what is f of 2
f of 2
is going to be equal to positive 8.
minus 24
minus 24
plus 2. so this is 10 minus 24 which is
equal to negative 14. so let's say this
is the point negative 14 right over here
check it out a little bit let's say this
is negative 14. so this is f of 2 right
over there and we saw already that the
slope is negative as we approach it so
we are our function is decreasing as we
approach it
and then right there the slope is 0. we
figured that out earlier that's how we
identified it being a critical point and
then the slope is increasing after that
the derivative is positive the slope is
increasing so this is our sketch of what
func of what f of x could look like
given that these are the critical points
we were able to identify f of or we were
able to identify 2 as a minimum point so
this was a minimum value the function
takes on a minimum value when x is equal
to 2 and the function took on a maximum
value when f was equal to
negative 2.